hello I'm Gavin down with a slow mo guys
I'm cringing slightly because Dan has a
katana sword at my throat level I
actually use this to shave even just
joking about that make orange because I
know how immensely sharp that is you can
see it you can see the point just
disappear into nothingness
oh we're gonna slice up some water balls
you always see those compilations are
very satisfying things especially in gif
form and one of them is just slicing
through balls with a katana yeah I mean
I'm sure this is sharp enough but it
depends on my skill whether I can
actually get all through those how are
you great your skills as a swordsman not
the best I mean you don't really learn
it in the army I guess unless sure I
don't know in the cavalry or an office
or yeah music katana sword op on the
horse yeah yeah off you go
alright let's get to the slicing and the
Dyson don't listen the Phantom folks
fork a thousand frames a second I've got
a long trigger cable so I can be over
there just the case then let's go of the
sword or or it's cheap and it just flies
straight out of the hill who knows you
want goggles or anything well in case I
get a sword in the eye so I don't know
whoopsie just looking out for you be
Cheers be alright how many do you think
I'll get through with my first because
I've never done this before I think
you'll go like [ __ ] and get like 6 yeah
yeah ready yeah
you're absolutely right I got through
like four and messed it up I'm so bad at
this I just saw water go all over the
fathoms I probably should move it back a
bit yeah I'm just concentrating too much
it got deflected so perfectly that it
just caught this one bottle here right
on the lid and like made a little leaky
hole you could have done that if you
tried
imagine that open this bottle for me so
thank you alright we reducing the amount
to a measly ten measly ten it's not the
blades fault because it's just going
straight through them you saw this
happening as your blade hits at this
angle it just drives that angle that
whatever since white and we have is like
amplified when you go through it has to
be pitch perfect on the where it hits
and how it hits to go through all of
them yeah if I'm even slightly off on
the angle it's just gone it's very
difficult goodness me got no idea how
many got through there it was about
seven that's my record so far it's not
bad
ready Warby really to go I'm gonna hold
this order slightly like downwards
angles so that hopefully when I swing
it's gonna just stay level as opposed to
going up very okay yep you ready yeah
it feels weird hole not that but there
we go way better way bear that you found
your calling now flip that was just went
through like butter
they're all like very similar height
really this just just popped off but
hold in there yeah so wait he was just
holding water woof so where you chop
that and it fell and landed with water
in it yeah I didn't even realize it had
water in it because I picked it up and I
was just like whoa see you angle it
slightly down
yeah angled it down which doesn't fit
naturally in the hands
oh my every bottle still has water in
the top
that was perfect oh god I didn't knock
anything at all just went straight
through some of the bottles barely know
it look some of this one landed with
water inside it it looks like the
bottles been somehow trapped in the
table like it's like it's like Willy
Wonka's bowl yes but my x-men did to the
tape before you move on to colored ones
Daniel yeah now that you've discovered
your true sorting method my calling in
life why don't we just put the rest of
the bottles up and see how many you can
get through yeah
okay so the last time it was ten and
this time I'm gonna cover the entire
table and see see what happened we're
pretty much to see if it's a fluke 16
it's an extra six a little bit more
pressure also switch the camera now to
4k because I just want to see the lovely
resolution on this one be a little bit
faster but the pixels no pressure then
no pressure weddings we're not even aim
oh god what do I'm just too much
what you went up again
yeah it looks like you got one more than
last time I did yeah I think we found it
it was just a fluke maybe God Oh what
come baby
why is it so I think a bigger don't ever
do I could see where you went wrong go
on the table I was like I'm sure that
would work again it's because right go
back go back rewind it this is the
problem I was looking at that they lost
the last bowl because I was like well
that's where I've got a swing - to be
fair the fact that you hit the table and
then hit 11 balls
that's impressive - I feel like the
technique definitely worked though
yeah it's just I hit the table first
yeah missing table well I just sliced it
clean off God look at it
we're at table dad know the janky table
is the junk leus yeah she tried glue it
back together again I feel like it if we
can find the little chunk put it down go
here is oh let's get that back oh yeah
can't believe I hit the table first what
a mug okay the colors already yeah
better prepare for a sticky mess on this
one oh yeah we'll do it a bit twice I'll
go wide and tight it's lower on the on
the closer okay
yeah what colourful sticky busy man
oh I just put this lens on - oh no is it
got Kate Kate the house
definitely went up again there how can
you tell
no I did I wanted to just leave them
completely where they were but because
the pot they kind of bang and explode
yeah so just go everywhere we'll get
there we'll get a closer up mount one
now nailed it nailed it felt so much
better
oh oh sorry B oh geez that's how you get
ants every video that goes by the resale
value of this place goes down surrender
it's like painting a place I feel me
sorry guys just taints it
it's cool how they the the empty space
clouds up as a as they are breached car
it's amazing how much brighter it gets
after the hit like this is quite a dark
image yeah then see on the histogram as
soon as it starts having it all the
light goes up oh wow yeah it's how much
there's so many brighter pixels oh
that's cool is it cuz the water's
reflecting the light is that what's good
what is is it a fizz it's just making
the liquid whiter than it was before and
also you got the Sun glistening realizin
yeah so I won't let my little pan there
yeah nice strong very sturdy the action
was gonna go to the right so I'll wait
for you to be done and go did you make
the noise as well I may have done it may
have done
can't believe actually managed to get
through all those balls and it was so
much easier when I angled it right it
just went through all of them it just
felt like butter there's nothing my
favorite shot is just the shard of
tables flying all right I missed that it
was just too hard too many bottles
they're very satisfying footage I can
see I can see that perfect one being
turned into a gif of just like oh it's
nice to look at and I don't know why
yeah and then someone's gonna end it
just before it goes through the last one
yeah we still enjoy hopefully you
enjoyed that video feel free to follow
us on Twitter you can subscribe to this
channel we also have a second channel
you do BTS and all that and we will
hopefully see you in the next video
because this is what we do on this
channel we continually make slow-mo
videos until the end of time which with
all these cameras forever really far
away yeah